ça fait 10 15 ans
françois pérusse musicien humoriste
comédien jeu vous incarnez un des rôles
principaux dans le film de guillaume
lambert niagara mais pourquoi vous
mettre ainsi en danger c'est quoi c'est
guillaume lambert qui vous a convaincu
guillaume il y est pour beaucoup j'ai
accepté ce projet l'eau parce que j'aime
bien la personne qui m'a donc proposé et
il me rassure et puis pourquoi ils pensé
à - s'est immolé explique quand je
souris est proche d'un air grave
c'est vrai je l'air grave quand je
réponds moi ma conjointe peut dire ça
est-ce que ça va du oui ça va je suis en
train de penser qu est-ce que
j'ai l'air grave qu'un show hip hop et
puis un peu ma façon de m'exprimer ma
façon d'être mon visage mes shows il
voyait dans mon dans mon langage
corporel que je correspondais au
personnage auquel il avait passé j'ai
fait confiance en guy young j'ai dit ok
allons-y
bonjour le 28 octobre 10 991 j'avais 31
ans le tome 1 de l'album du peuple a
célébré ses 30 ans l'an dernier oui
l'album du peuple c'est 15 disques 2
millions d'exemplaires vendus mais je
veux toujours posé la question comment à
quel moment vous avez décidé d'accélérer
des voix pour en faire de l'humour quel
jour un samedi matin ensoleillé j'avais
huit ans
j'avais un magnétophone qui appartenait
à mon père que fonctionner sur piles
j'enregistrais ma voix sur des cassettes
faisait des fausses publicités je
m'amusais registre il choisit niaiseries
je trouvais ça bien rigolo et j'ai
enregistré sur son appareil à piles et
je suis demandée par contre mais les
piles faiblissent est coordonnée
là-bas mais le moteur faiblissait aussi
tourné plus lentement mais
ça ne donnait pas une impression
d'accélération ça donnait l'impression
que c'est alain plus en plus lentement
plus tôt et puis nous allons donner mon
père a acheté un adaptateur électrique
pour faire fonctionner l'appareil j'ai
réécouté mais bang avec le moteur qu'il
tourne à une vitesse normale et là
c'était hyper hyper aiguë et plus
accéléré et j'ai trouvé cet ordre mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé de 8 ans à 30
ans parce que le succès est venu tard
pour vous le 12 ans de radio
communautaire à québec puis à 30 a beau
le succès j'ai commencé à jouer de la
basse avec lui de l'hérault joliette par
le truchement de mon frère qui était son
chef d'orchestre
et c'est tombé dans l'oreille de l'udc
et son gérant pierre dumont gaiement
gérant aujourd'hui et de mon frère et
tous ceux qui ont décidé de me faire
faire une publicité pour annoncer
l'album sauvez mon âme sur lesquels j'ai
joué en utilisant cette technologie
l'eau et mes textes et choc pour faire 1
30 secondes je les fais ça jouer dans
toutes les régions du québec et j'ai eu
un appel de ckoi à l'époque c'est comme
ça que la chorale la croche danser sur
ce téléphone il accrochera y mouille à
ckoi je donne mon personnage préféré
c'est le bloc qui magasin avec mon rôle
à broadway
boulot qui vous inspirer dans la vraie
vie pour ses personnages un moment donné
quelqu'un qui avec qui j'ai travaillé
pas longtemps dans un magasin sur la rue
cartier à québec qui lui coûtait parler
à ses fournisseurs qui était un petit
peu baveuse et ouais
ok les bronzés mais pas de mal à marquer
ils parlaient d'eux-mêmes puissamment
inspiré un peu un baveux qui parlent au
téléphone qui ridiculise tout ce que son
interlocuteur dit y'a pas de nom ce
cadeau c'est le gars qui magasinent j'ai
jamais donné de nom fait je peux plus
rien donné un super trop longtemps qu'un
point de noyer bêtisier oui bon
anniversaire à des ballons et de petits
clous dollars de commandes
je veux parler de votre succès en france
80 capsules huit ans deux reprises cette
négo store la bombe reprenez classement
dans la rue leurs 75 au sein des membres
de ma chaîne youtube sont des européens
francophones et je suis le premier
surpris je vois vos surprises je prie
aussi
mais je tenterai de mon blake vos
expressions mais il a fallu que je
m'adapte alors j'ai même un accent
jeunes et j'en ai fait une coupe
récemment et je me suis aperçu que c'est
pas les mêmes muscles que pour l'accent
québécois se faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas parler en français
international
c'est pas les mêmes muscles on sait pas
les mêmes intonations c'est qu'on ne dit
pas long terme si longtemps
[Applaudissements]
françois pérusse je termine en vous
remerciant parce qu'il ya plus de 25 ans
avait passé deux heures vous travaillé
24 heures sur 24 à l'époque faisait
passer deux heures avec un jeune
journaliste pour l'encourager
et il a continué ce journal est ce la
fin la médecine merci beaucoup aux yeux
baissés nommé wanda c'est merci non ben
beau nous aussi j'ai 27 c'est que ça
ferait ça fait ma semaine ça ça fait
vraiment mal
[Musique]
des supers et d'éliminer 10 millions de
vues des talents